the 17th century English philosopher
John Locke is to be remembered for his
wise and brilliant contributions to
three great issues that continue to
concern us to this day how we should
educate our children who should rule
over us and what we should do about
people who have different religious
ideas to us Locke was born into a quiet
Somerset village in 1632 he was 10 years
old when the English Civil War broke out
and his father became a captain in the
parliamentary army King Charles the
first was publicly executed in 1649 just
a few feet away from where Locke was
studying at Westminster School the
screams of the crowds heard in the
library marked him deeply Locke went on
to study medicine at Oxford and planned
to be a doctor but his life changed
significantly when by chance he became
acquainted with the dashing and highly
ambitious Whig politician Anthony Ashley
Cooper known as the first Earl of
Shaftesbury who'd come to Oxford to look
for a cure for a liver disease he had
Cooper suggested that Locke moved to
London to become part of his household
the offer was hard to resist and once
part of Cooper's entourage Locke began
to participate in the great scientific
educational religious and political
debates for the day along the way he
also helped to cure Shaftesbury of his
liver complaint earning his lifelong
gratitude the first question Locke grew
fascinated by was what to do with people
who don't agree with your religious
views in breaking away from the Catholic
Church under Henry the eighth in the
16th century English Protestantism had
started a process of noisy questioning
of religion that couldn't now easily be
stopped because this was threatening to
get out of hand there were arguments
that there should be total government
control over religion and a hard crack
down on dissenters but Locke became one
of the foremost advocates of freedom of
belief in his beautiful essay concerning
toleration written in 1667 here he
advocated toleration on the basis of
three points firstly because earthly
judges the
State in particular and human beings in
general cannot dependably evaluate the
truth claims of competing religious
standpoints secondly even if they could
enforcing a single true religion would
never work because you can't be
compelled into belief through violence
and thirdly coercing religious
uniformity leads to far more social
disorder than allowing diversity Locke
argued that the ultimate aim of the
state was just to preserve the quiet and
comfortable living of men in society but
that it have nothing to do with the good
of men's souls religion was a personal
choice and churches were voluntary
organisations which could set their own
rules and be left to it it was thanks to
Locke's influence that the idea of
locking up people for their beliefs fell
entirely out of favour by the 18th
century other European nations looked
with envy at England a place where what
you happen to believe was simply deemed
irrelevant to your status or prospects
this was a truly remarkable achievement
for one book by one man to have set in
train but Locke didn't stop there in
1689 he published a second extraordinary
book the true treatises of government
this tried to answer the question of who
should rule the country and on what
legitimate basis one common yet
increasingly fanciful notion at the time
was that political Authority derived
directly from God but a more recent
explanation from Thomas Hobbes had
asserted that the totalitarian power of
Kings was justified by their ability to
keep order and prevent repetitions of
the chaos that had reigned Hobbes had
insisted in the time before powerful
governments and that he had called the
state of nature by painting the state of
nature in the darkest colors Hobbes had
asked his readers to set themselves low
expectations for what a decent ruler was
meant to be anything better than the
savagery of the Stone Age was legitimate
and rulers had no responsibility to
guarantee religious freedom or human
rights but now in the first treatise
Locke thoroughly demolished the
scriptural claim that God had created
kings and in the second treatise he took
on Hobbes's ideas about the state of
nature Locke agreed with Hobbes that
before and without government they
would have been a state of nature but he
disagreed what this place would actually
have been like he argued that it would
have been broadly peaceful and that in
agreeing to submit to governments
people had therefore not fearfully
agreed to surrender all their rights in
fact they possessed a range of
inalienable or natural rights that no
ruler could ever take away Locke
insisted that people had voluntarily
consented to cede some of their personal
freedoms but only insofar as it better
preserved their rights they couldn't be
expected to give up these rights
entirely as that would just defeat the
point of joining society in the first
place if a ruler started to act like a
tyrant and unfairly deprived their
subjects of their freedom or property
the subjects were then entirely within
their rights to withdraw their consent
overthrow their ruler and set up a new
government Locke's work
hugely influenced the development of
Western societies and in particular the
American Declaration of Independence for
example in its insistence on the
separation of church and state and in
the second Amendment right to bear arms
a clear descendent of Locke's view that
a people should always retain both the
right and the means to overthrow
government Locke made one other great
innovation this time in education in his
book some thoughts concerning education
of 1693 this was possibly the most
influential book on education ever
written
in 1684 an aristocrat called Edward
Clark asked Locke for advice on raising
his son and heir though he was unmarried
and never had children of his own and by
all accounts didn't actually enjoy their
company that much Locke responded with a
series of letters that he eventually
turned into a book Locke began by saying
that all of us start off in life with
minds that are blank tabula rasa
he called them in another famous work
his essay concerning human understanding
of 1689 idea ran contrary to prevailing
views that our minds are fitted at birth
with all sorts of ideas about religion
ethics morality and government Locke
argued that everything we think believe
no or conjecture is actually derived
from experience from the simple ideas we
receive from sensations in the outside
world
or internal reflections on the processes
of our own understandings led Locke to
the belief that education was absolutely
crucial to how people turn out I think I
may say that of all the men we meet with
nine parts of ten are what they are good
or evil useful or not because of
Education Locke believed that we are
very vulnerable to the ideas that people
place in our minds when we're children
he wrote the little and almost
insensible impressions on our tender
infancy 'he's have very important and
lasting consequences he argued that the
association of ideas that one makes when
young are more important than those made
later because they are the foundations
of ourselves so he warned famously
against letting a foolish maid convince
a child that goblins and spirits are
associated with the night for darkness
shall ever afterwards bring with it
those frightful ideas Locke is the
forerunner of our own parenting
techniques in which we proceed under the
assumption that everything that happens
to a child whether they have a nice time
at the zoo with us or get enough cuddles
at the age of four plays an enormous
role in later life these ideas didn't
pop into our heads just like that
without us necessarily knowing it they
are the work of a gaunt wise philosopher
of 17th century England Locke also had
some fascinating thoughts about what
should be on the educational curriculum
he hated the idea of children learning
what he called useless subjects like
Latin Greek music or poetry only to
study what would be of practical
assistance to them later in life which
meant science ethics business and what
we nowadays call psychology instructions
on how we can best calm ourselves be
kind and understand others he wanted
though he didn't directly use the phrase
that we should study at schools of life
Locke died in October 1704 he was one of
the most famous men in Europe and
continues to influences hugely to this
day it is because of him that we
believed in religious toleration that we
believed that governments should not
tyrannize their subjects and that we try
so hard to give our own children
good childhoods
you